mathieu bouvette dans le cortège
plusieurs dizaines de manifestants
défilent dans les rues paraît
effectivement nom se retrouve dans cette
manifestation qui a été déclarée
autorisée qui est parti d'inde autour de
midi depuis la porte de saint cloud et
qui tenteront de marcher un défilé qui
se dirige la direction aux perrières
l'emmener sur le boulevard des maréchaux
ils sont une centaine de gilets jaunes à
s'être donné rendez-vous à manifester
pour cette manifestation qui a été
autorisée manifestation qui ce qui ce se
qui se déroule depuis toner dans une
ambiance bon enfant sans débordement
encadrés par les forces de l'ordre
je suis avec une décision que nous
expliquait un petit peu près c'était
important d'être là et qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent de cet acte 65 gilet jaune
merci de répondre à la question
lorsqu'on en est de cet acte 65 de gilet
jaune est bien toujours la même
mobilisation à fond partout en france
parce que ça n'est pas que sur paris la
mobilisation des gilet jaune depuis la
première heure se passe sur le sol
national
même en outre-mer qu'on n'oublie pas
donc il faut absolument rien lâcher
compte tenu de ce qui se passe encore
avec tous tes réformes
beaucoup de foyers ont perdu leur apl ya
une une réforme qui est en train de se
préparer pour la sécurité sociale
le pays va mal le peuple va mal il est
grand temps que macron ne comprennent
ils l'entendent
je répondrai aux personnes qui déclarent
que le mouvement les juges est en train
de s'essouffler après une année
s'essouffler tout est relatif qu'est ce
qu'ils appellent essoufflé pour moi y'a
rien qui s'essoufle parce que la
précarité grandissante la misère est
grandissante ce gouvernement est en
train de nous pondre des lois et des
réformes assassines qui pousse les gens
n'ont plus à sortir dans la rue pour
manifester mais à y vivre carrément des
familles entières des enfants dépend des
gens qui travaillent se retrouvent à la
rue avec femme enfants
il ya des personnes à mobilité réduite
aussi qui perdent leurs lois et leurs
foyers parce qu'il fait plus payer leur
loyer leur rente ne leur suffisent pas
pour payer toutes les charges et se
nourrir ce n'est pas normal la politique
qui est menée bien sûr qu'il faut des
réformes mais pas des réformes dans ce
sens là il est grand temps qu'ils
écoutent le peuple on voyait plusieurs
manifestations qui ont organisé l'année
dernière on avait l'habitude d'avoir un
seul point de ralliement avec une arme
anti les jaunes aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que c'est des différents
mouvements de jeunes qui s'organisent à
travers le pays comment on arrive à
perdre un petit peu en cohésion dans le
dans le clan des jeunes et jaune écoutez
les actions qui ont été menées
aujourd'hui par exemple sur paris
effectivement la manifestation qui a été
interdite c'est justement pour mettre le
point sur la discrimination que le
mouvement subit concernant le droit de
se rassembler de manifester sur paris
chacun lutte à sa façon nous nous
concernant nous avons essuyé aussi des
arrêtés préfectoraux et cetera des
échanges par mails qui prouve que c'est
difficile de trouver de choisir les
parcours qu'on veut que l'on souhaite
même si tous les parcours c'est nous
qu'ils imposent aux ça n'est pas la
préfecture qui le fait donc nous avons
choisi le choix nous avons fait plutôt
le choix de saisir les droits qui sont à
la disposition des citoyens afin de les
faire valoir par le biais d'actions
juridiques et pour cela nous sommes en
relation avec différents organismes des
efforts différents organismes de défense
de droits citoyens et bien merci
beaucoup comme vous l'avez entendu les
mêmes revendications que depuis le début
de ce mouvement d gilet jaune même si la
réforme des retraites a apparaît comme
un être une des revendications
primordial en ce moment alors que cette
loi devrait être votée donc les
manifestations les manifestants pardon
sont toujours sur place sont partis
depuis la porte de saint-cloud direction
perrière pour cette manifestation qui se
situe qui ce qui se passe qui se déroule
dans le calme pour le moment et
direction perrière et bien sûr nous
suivrons cette magnifique
durant les prochaines éditions de ce
journal